es ist einer der schönsten Orte
Österreichs nicht jede versteht das
Hallstadt selfie Hotspot jeden Tag
kommen sie knipsen sie und Posten es auf
insta
und nicht immer gelingt es dabei ruhig
zu sein
manchen wird es jetzt zu viel erzählt
der Bürgermeister Österreich ist in als
Ziel nicht zu heiß und pittoresk und
Hallstatt besonders man mag den nach wie
vor Werbung mit Hallstatt ganz egal auf
welchem Flughäfen international sieht
reisen sie sehen überall Bilder von
Hallstatt wenn man zum Österreich geht
sie wollen das ist keine Werbung für
Hallstatt geht nicht mehr so mal nicht
mehr so massiv kürzlich blockierten
einige hallstätte die Zufahrt zum Ort
bis zu zehntausend Tages Touristen
Treffen zu Spitzenzeiten auf gerade mal
740 Einwohner
die Gemeinde hat deshalb für die Zufahrt
zum Ort und die Zahl der Busse Grenzen
gesetzt trotzdem überwältigt die Menge
denn sofort gibt es Ausweichstrategien
weil immer mehr PKWs vielleicht kommen
immer mehr Kleinbusse Mietwagen wo 80
sind und und die bleiben dann auch
überall stehen wie anders war das vor
zwei Jahren als die Pandemie heißt Stadt
eine Atempause geschirrte
sie machte auch klar wie sehr der Ort
vom Tourismus abhängig ist
wir haben ca 60 Arbeitslose derzeit
voriges Jahr um die Zeit hatten wir
keinem 90 Prozent des Ortes Leben
eigentlich vom Tourismus betonte damals
der wird Thomas Pils
einfach totenstiele in jeder Hinsicht
auch am bangkonto
jetzt sind die Touristen zurück rund
eine Million pro Jahr wegen Post
corona-reise Lust und weil es hier
relativ kühl ist
man solle dankbar sein für die Gäste
meint der Wirt Thomas Pilz was denkt er
über den Hitze Sommer bei uns ist es
manchmal zu kühl was ich bin dann immer
wieder froh wenn mir die Sonne auf dem
Bauch scheint die Leute von nach wie vor
in den Süden die dauernautobahn war den
ganzen Sommer verstopft das ist
vielleicht das größere Problem als die
Hitze dort in seiner Ingolstädter
Dachkammer hat Tourismus Forscher Markus
pillmeier die Welt im Blick over tourism
und Klimawandel ist das Problem der
Branche Hallstadt werde noch einiges
erleben wir können aber jetzt schon
davon ausgehen dass durch die
Extremwetter Ereignisse Mittelmeerraum
es zu einer Verschiebung der Reiseströme
vermutlich kommen wird für Orte wie
Hallstatt und ähnliche wird natürlich
sich der Druck noch einmal deutlich
erhöhen auch das ist Extremwetter
Klimawandel hat für Österreich sichtbare
Nachteile selten war kürzlich
abgeschnitten
rund fünf Tage dauerte die Reparatur
jetzt ist Sölden wieder erreichbar
und in der heimwirtschaft gampertalia
brutzelt Jakob prante wieder
Kaiserschmarrn für seine Gäste
ob extrem Wetter nun häufiger passiert
für ihn jedenfalls ist es der alpine
Normalfall ich sage immer mehr leben von
der Natur da müssen wir auch miterleben
und es wird einmal im Winter viel Schnee
das ein und im Sommer wird es irgendwann
wieder Hochwasser geben das hat immer
geben und wird immer wieder geben Geld
seine Gäste kommen häufig zu Fuß und wie
gut dass sie wieder da sind
vor zwei Jahren war ich auf der
gampetaria die einzige Besucherin und
Jakob Brandl hatte ungewöhnlich viel
Zeit für seine Kühe und seine Enkel eine
Nachdenkpause nannte er es
sieht es eher als Chance
weil man da sehr vieles auch ein
bisschen wieder zurückkommt auf die
Normalität die Pandemie ist vorbei doch
normal ist das nicht in Süden
Österreich erlebt einen Sommer der
extreme fast zehn Prozent des globalen
CO2 Ausstoßes verantwortete Tourismus
sagt pillmeier sowohl die Tourismus
Anbieter müssen eine Antwort darauf
geben
wie sie diesen stark Wetter Ereignis
oder Extremwerte Ereignissen begegnen
und genauso muss aber auch den Reisenden
klar sein dass sie auch ihren Teil dazu
beizutragen haben und wenn es nur eine
Alternative Anreise ist in Form von Zug
hat das Umdenken begonnen österreich hat
diesen Sommer rund 2% mehr Gäste als vor
Corona
Aktivurlaub im Kühler Höhe ohne lange
Flugreisen auf der Gampe Tarja schätzen
Sie das doch nicht alle Gäste treibt das
Klima gewissen her die Schmitz kommen
seit 30 Jahren diesmal hat es wegen der
unterspülten Straße doppelt so lang
gedauert wie sonst das hat zwar vor 20
Jahren auch schon gegeben muss man
fairerweise sagen dass das ein bisschen
zunehmend ist ich glaube da müssen wir
nicht streiten weil das macht mir jetzt
keine keine Sorgen vielleicht bin ich
auseinander zu alt für schon wird jünger
ist sieht das anders
diese Angst vor vom Klimawandel oder vor
der Klimakatastrophe muss man eigentlich
fast sagen die ist schon zunehmend und
vor allem denkt man halt schon irgendwie
nicht nur an mich sondern auch an die
nächsten Generationen Jakob Brandl ist
berufsoptimist im Klimawandel sei die
Höhe ihr Vorteil aber schon seit Jahren
setzt sich die ganze Familie ein für
regionalerin sanfteren Tourismus das
Umdenken dauert trotz Pandemie und
extrem Sommer viele sind im gleichen
dort drinnen und man vergisst sehr
schnell ist es selber wenn man auf der
Autobahn seinen Umwelt dazu kommt die
nächste Viertelstunde denkt man noch
darüber nach ist das schon vergessen
nachher drückt man genau wieder gleich
aufs Gaspedal
der Wasserstand im Ötztal ist
zurückgegangen das Tal scheint
durchzuatmen Kraft gewinnen für das was
noch kommt denn der Klimawandel
verändert den Tourismus auch in der
nahen Wintersaison
[Musik]